my friends this is the Second Industrial
Revolution like I just want you to know
especially for the 20 and 30 year olds
in this crowd because I is a 40 year old
soon in November and a month holy crap
[ __ ] and the people that are older than
me we didn't get as lucky as you did
this is this is the generation like this
is the sweet spot this is the land grab
this is what happens everybody's got
their own generations and their own
great things and their own bad things if
you just want to talk about
entrepreneurship if you just want to
talk about having an at-bat to build
something for yourself that you own and
do something that you like this is
better than 1987 this is better than
1974 this is better than 1963 and the
one thing that I asked you to do is to
not look back and regret that you
wavered on the moment that was available
to you the only thing that's not fun the
only thing you regret is the things that
you don't do it's just the way it is
like even if you think of random dumb
stuff like not asking out that person in
high school or so there's stuff lingers
it's the stuff that you don't do that
bothers you and so for the purebred
entrepreneurs in here that haven't
decided to make that leap or take that
at bat
I implore you to do so right away
because this window closes - it's just
supply and demand as you get more and
more entrepreneurs and as more and more
people do it more and more at-bats fall
off the stream it was a lot a lot easier
to start social media sites in 2003 four
five six and seven that are is now
because 9,000 photo social apps hit the
App Store every day and so if you hear
that and you hear the last little part
of my rant would just know yourself I'm
trying to point you in a direction of
where the opportunity is because there
is so much white space still available
to build in businesses yet people are
really attracted to the one or two
billion dollar exits and they think they
need to guys for every Instagram there's
80,000 insta shits
so everybody's chasing these unicorns
these once-in-a-lifetime do you know how
phenomenal it sounds to your
grandparents if you told them that you
built a business that you own that you
run that you like doing and you make
$200,000 a year do you know what kind of
Nirvana that actually is in the scheme
of things and so we are not grounding
this entrepreneurial startup
conversation and the right thing we're
grounding it in these headlines of the
five or six things snapchat Facebook
Instagram Eber and we're not talking
about the tens of thousands of
opportunities there are if you actually
take a step back understand what's
happening try to build something around
your pain point like your pain point
might be your three kids piss you off
all the time like that's a real pain
point right like I don't know create an
uber for like baby sitters like you like
you know like like there is so many ways
to build businesses and if you just sit
back right now and think about how much
money you make double that amount and
then think about being able to do
something on your own terms now all of a
sudden you've ground yourself in a
totally different conversation than this
weird need to like be the next sucks
right or like change the world or things
of that nature and so I'm looking for
practicality I'm looking for real
practicality because practical business
building has never been easier